well welcome welcome back to your
reunions are here for that welcome back
to campus for any reason and welcome
spring Cardinal I'm sure you're enjoying
it enjoy the buggy races today and you
get over the Midway and take in all the
mixed carnival special in which I'm sure
you remember well I was chatting before
about buggy we have a chief mechanic
from a buggy team that will be
introducing to you later on and reminded
me that it's surprising to me no more
but it used to be how many alumni when I
would meet the one say to me you know i
learned more from being chief mechanic
my buggy team or head of my booth
committee that I did in four years in
class at first time ago wait a minute
what is
and then I realized it's probably true
at least in terms of the things that
they were even when we have fun learning
a lot and our students get very
passionate about fun things like buggy
it's one of the things the mix eternity
millender is special I'm going to give
you a rolly brief update on the
University and some highlights have a
little time for questions and answers
and then i'm going to introduce to you a
student panel and i want to save as much
time for them as possible because
hearing from our students is much better
in my view than urine from anybody else
at the University including and
especially the President and to get a
glimpse of what really goes on here and
my Carnegie Mellon's like today you need
to hear from the students let me pick up
on a reference to Jay made which i think
is always very important for alumni
especially to keep in mind we're
certainly a different University than
the one you attended in the sense of our
physical appearance we don't know gotta
have more programs of various kinds or
different ones that when you were here
we've discontinued some printing
management which is still a sore point
for a lot of alumni but we started other
words like my human computer interaction
which we haven't done think of as the
21st century version
pretty management but there are some
things that haven't changed at all and
that's the real message that I want to
convey to you the same values on which
Carnegie Tech driving in technical
schools and in Carnegie Tech were
founded the same values that guided the
University when you were here whenever
you were here are the same values that
we followed tonight if you ask any
person in random on this campus today /
initially it with the university as a
student staff member of fact you meant
when you asked him quick what makes
Carnegie Mellon what it is you're likely
to hear the same answer from all which
itself is going we are a university that
nose itself well that can't be said by a
lot of places but we are distinctive and
we know that and we know ourselves and I
think we like or we know about ourselves
but what you'd like you to hear would be
well if you ask a student the first
thing would say is hard work JS right
about that the students still work very
very hard some would say that mostly
would say where the hardest-working
student body in the world in history
probably or some version of that and
they're probably not that far off and we
don't apologize for the rigor of our
programs and their depth and the
challenge that we present to our
students are things that we do very
intentional and it's the reason why our
students do so well when they leave you
tongue-in-cheek comment life is easy
after Carnegie Mellon of course what
that means is you're so well-prepared
step is when it's workplace or graduate
school or professionals this university
prepares you very much we work hard but
trust selected here or it's like problem
solving same phrase you were when you
were here collaboration
interdisciplinary collaborations what we
call it today or teamwork that's
something that's been around as explicit
part of Carnegie Mellon for about 60
years but in the last ten years it's
really coming before we've understood
how valuable that is and we needed a key
part of everything we do including the
undergraduate program and you'll
probably hear innovation doing things a
different way not being satisfied with
the status quo about any status called
the world status quo with the way we do
things on campus always put in to get
better that's Carnegie Mellon it's
turning Tamela today was Carnegie Mellon
20 years ago that was Carnegie Mellon 70
years ago just simply called another
dinner so we changed a lot but deep down
in our hearts and very importantly the
same university that you attended
we'll hear from our students later but
let me say a few words about student
body today is just phenomenal they
comfortable they're very highly selected
from a two large applicant pool which
I'll come back to well let me tell you
about it down so for next the freshman
class doubleheader in September August
session we receive over 26,000
applications for 1,400 spaces you do the
math now the 26,000 itself it's a nice
compliment the University of its
problematic our admissions office says
prided itself on its unfailing
commitment and ability to Madison that
commitment of reviewing every
application individual and stilted that
this year but for still recovering from
have you done it it just really become a
kind of problematic and out as an
indication of how wonderful the students
are but also the nature of a challenge
in your missions process right now
Carnegie Mellon for next year rejected
I'm about to tell you students that we
reject 309 valedictorians is our kids
first inner classes got rejected 1200
kids with straight A's and thirty kids
would perfect SATs I got rejected so
what a parent calls me up and says how
could you reject it my kid actually my
response key stages
but that's in any prospective parents
who good that because you would have
fought off your chair screaming out of
the room there's just so much stress in
the system stays and this is one and I
don't envy being on the other side of
this I know what you're thinking and I
think the same thing I could not gotten
into might the schools i attended either
that or could not get into it today you
could have the world is just different
that's but it really is something the
students are phenomenal and one of the
things that's notable in recent years is
frequency with our which our students
win these big prestigious national
scholarships like the roads getting
roads this year but we've gotten other
prestigious ones last year we had our
first Marshall scholar in 41 years
Sheila I Ramesh was majoring humanities
and social sciences & Music keep that in
mind I'll come back I said you're curvy
right Madison social sciences and music
this year you'll be meeting her later
swati version was a science humanities
scholars and chemistry major on a
Churchill scholarship that's phenomenal
cheap the Churchill is to Cambridge
but the roads is to hospital except it's
actually harder with that arose because
they're only 14 cambridge insurgents and
slightly one of those congratulations
against one and there are many more
goldwater's Truman's our students are
applied for dates and numbers of the
narrative and they're winning them as
well and indicates really involving
students so I mentioned Sheila's
combination of h NS s music these kinds
of multidisciplinary combinations have
become the norm around and it's a
marvelous thing to see for one thing you
have to be the kind of person who can
succeed at humanities and social
sciences or engineering or something
else and something else like music or a
modern language very quite common
combination of stays or things like
computer science and Chinese i'm not
talking about taking a course attorneys
talking about major chinese or your
major your size i'm impressed by what
that shows you is both this sort of
multidisciplinary approach the things
which i talked about before but also the
university success in making it possible
for closer to possible sometimes it is
for students to do these tendencies I
think it's a great thing these are kids
who will have big impact you heard Jays
reference to how global we become just
to put a name on some of the countries
that Jay was referring to summary terms
we have undergraduate program in Qatar
at least they have graduate programs in
Portugal australia greece singapore and
elsewhere korea japan sorry it's hard to
keep track symptoms again as you also
heard all this is happening in the last
few years this has been a tremendous
thing for the university I think
something that would be extremely
important for our strategic positioning
and our ability to be a media nurse in
the future of course the campus has
changed and a lot of ways dramatically
depending on when you graduated even if
you graduated five years ago there have
been significant changes the biggest
recent change is the building of the
computer science companies the bill
gates and Henry Hillman complex what a
part of its name it's part of her
the two leading donors to that building
it's a wonderful note however you might
feel about it from the outside I know it
doesn't have a buff color brick a
reminder that all the time by many
people inside i hope you get inside it
is just tremendous it's exactly the kind
of space that everybody would like to
have a computer scientist especially a
cherished great because it has the kind
of of the structured in a lot of
unstructured informal places or
collaboration in and discussion it
really is a wonderful tool and you might
remember what it replaced sort of a
collection of buildings that generously
can be called derelict fishermen after
very nice goal was way past their useful
bodies and that's been replaced creating
a much nicer setting and saturating a
whole campus down below or quadratic
equation said that never existed before
really is terrific now less apparently
but no less significant is our expansion
of a campus for the last year we've
acquired all the land between the
university's current Western footprint
and Christ or put another way everything
on the other side of the hollow on both
sides of the street except for those
three buildings at the end
or that is panther hollow in if survive
forever they'd give every what that I
guess you would have to sustain your rid
of the jewish university center and
maybe hood starbucks we don't know those
i'll be home everything else around it
is a very big deal for us the
university's campus has not expanded in
forever i think where we still remember
the last time we were able to push out
the footprint nothing's built on it yet
as you would have noticed and we're
developing plans now but it's likely to
include some kind of mixed-use
development including commercial
development and also get in that
including at least one more building
intended for companies that would be
attracted to Pittsburgh to create
searching Elvis ownership there's a
building on campus net it's a cross it's
right at the edge of the hollow it's the
first thing you see coming to the campus
from pitt that's across this new
quadrangle from the gate sir that was a
building built to serve a purpose it
opened about five or six years ago and
it has in it Apple Intel and Google
companies that have never been
invincible
and we're attracted because of that
building to be close to Carnegie Mellon
fed on our campus it's worked out
incredibly well so well that Google
which went from two people to 100 people
in four years Desna brett has rattled
and they're leaving to move into a new
development in beast liberty now
remember your Pittsburgh geography and
no matter when you lived here even five
years ago if I had told you Google's can
open a major engineering center and in
east liberty you should have said get
out of here and grace it's true and this
is a tremendous thing for the city as it
is for the University who was moving out
but the new Disney lab yes we have
disney research center here 02 and here
we'll be moving in and other companies
are lining up to fill the space it's
been a tremendous development for
university and for city and the city is
doing very well in fact so well that
last fall President Obama chose
Pittsburgh host the g20 summit of global
leaders it was a stunning announcement
Pittsburgh became the first city that
was not a cap of a national capital to
host a meeting like them and we were
chosen by the Obama administration
because we are we become the model of
the older industrial city which is
transformed itself from its old and
pass to a knowledge-based diversify
become it's been a tremendous
successfully and Carnegie Mellon is at
the heart of that in fact just one
statistic in the depth of the recent
recession our unemployment right here in
Pittsburgh reached about seven and a
half percent nationally of course you
know reach ten percent plus which is an
indication of on that saving a recession
or not that employment here may still go
up again but we've done very very well
and again the universities have had
already doing recession of course has
had had impact of which in every
organization in the country are communal
world including Carnegie Mellon
University our endowment last year lost
about a quarter of its value it's a lot
of money it's recovered nicely this year
so far since July first through the end
of March it's gained back about fifteen
percent that's very good but the way we
manage and spend our identity the effect
of that loss last year will be with us
for another three years so we've had to
mind our P's and Q's and pull in our
belt and and we've got were fine
universities and strong shape we
instituted a series of budget cuts and
campus responded very well to it he
froze all salaries last year and
announced that is from curlier announced
the one percent salary for next year
which is almost like
so people are feeling but we got jobs
not had to do many layoffs at all in the
University of this quite strong even
while we've been I should have one worth
it's been interesting how the
recession's had sort of delayed impact
on Carnegie Mellon the endowment loss
the effects of it being felt now and
will over two or three years another
delayed effect in terms of gleason how
and when it got manifest was on our
undergraduate student so undergraduate
financial aid we're now projecting will
be four million dollars higher in the
current year than what we projected at
the beginning that's because they need
our student body this corner and we're
projecting that financial aid
requirements for next year in the early
in the year after will be 16 million
dollars higher again because of the
effect of the economy on our families
and we're responding to that of course
all of this puts pressure on our budget
as I started to say even in the face of
these cuts and slowing down the
university must not stop over the head
strategic and we have continued to make
very selective he hires
in areas that are strategically
important to the University we continue
to invest in facilities we've got the
money to do so which we feel we just
can't delay doing because it's to a
point of the University and will
continue to do so the university is in
good shape financially solid shape but
we have this continuing effect of the
economy that will be with us for
probably about three more years money
unavoidably is important horse and the
revenues for Carnegie Mellon come from
three sources and only three sources
from tuition dollars from sponsored
research largely from the fair
government very good at winning those
grants what is a very competitive
environment and finally in Donald Rawls
and gifts gifts large you from our
graduates from our alumni
we started a capital campaign some years
ago now a campaign that's gone well in
every respect we've raised over six
hundred million dollars towards our
billion dollar bowl and yes fundraising
is slow down during recession and
afterwards you would expect but the
people interaction part of the campaign
is continued and pacing around very well
in fact this campaign is as much about
engaging our alumni alumni as it is
about raising money you heard che refer
to the approximately 15 international
alumni chapters that's up for only two
international um nine chapters at the
beginning of the campaign in fact we
have three times more alumni chapters
and totally round the world that we did
at the beginning of the campaign we have
many many more alumni coming back for
events like this we're delighted by the
response our alumni to carnival and
unions at carnival time this is all part
of a concerted effort by us to engage
our alum because we understand how
important that is you are important to
us not just as a source of money
but you're giving is very important to
us but you're important to us in every
other way you are our eyes and years of
the world you are the best billboards
the university can have in terms of
advertisement advertising consultant it
really is you that shaped the reputation
of this year's when people know you're a
carnegie mellon graduate LOL oh ok so
they graduate good people who have
impact alumni are very very important
tools and engaging you get some very
high priority force as part of our
effort to increase alumni participation
we launched our loyal Scots program if I
have a love Scott's t-shirt I'm sure you
all have one under your shorts just go
like that and show us there it is a
proud owner of a loyal Scott t-shirt
thank you very much you know I do that
again and show it to the camera this
program was put together to encourage
you to be involved it recognizes your
attendance of events like this your
volunteerism on behalf of the university
your relatives to advocate on behalf on
the university and your annual give it's
easy to join really easy to join there's
a table out here somewhere right outside
the room
there's one buggy races there's one over
the Midway and they ended his college
would be more than happy to sign you up
so please take advantage now in some
turning Mel is doing very very well it's
an exciting time for us session aside
continue to charge ahead with your
phenomenal students brilliant faculty
together they do just tremendous things
and it's something we should all be very
proud thank you very much for coming
back and for listening to me today thank
you so we have time for a couple of
questions before we turn to our student
panel any questions for me about
anything that someone can be on anything
at all yes sir how do you have you got
financed the campuses
leave I put I'm very glad ask that
question the question was how do we
finance our efforts outside of
Pittsburgh International so we made a
commitment to ourselves into our Board
of Trustees what we set out to do this
that we would never subsidize
international program from Pittsburgh
these programs that have to at least pay
for themselves they have to be break
even or better and we do that by having
a source of funding locally usually a
government spell the government of Qatar
funds US government of Portugal funds us
in touch in some last year our
international programs produced a
surplus of 10 million dollars which went
to support terrorist operations so
that's a pledge we it's got to be cannot
take away from Pittsburgh's operations
other questions
I couldn't hear the question question
was have you although I do what is the
tuition up so hold on your city it's
about forty thousand dollars and that's
just tuition when you have moving board
and books and fees it comes to about
fifty thousand dollars a year that it's
not a number we're proud of we would
tell you though that it's less than the
actual cost of educating soon which is
we would say also with some confidence
that it's worth that students get
tremendous value and families
contributes value by that industrial
feel very good about won't be delivered
and the product we offer I struggle with
this and I try to understand you can EQ
look at inflation rates and yes you know
the tuition increases your ear and how
paste the consumer price index by
substantial margin in fact our cost
there's actually a separate inflation
index or higher education those also
caught up faster than the CBI
but I try to put in kind of commonplace
terms so I'd think about how much it
costs I went to college a little bit
less it was about two thousand dollars a
year seemed like a lot of money than it
was and I reflect on the fact that a new
chevrolet camaro cost 2,500 hours now
i'm not saying you could that you would
spend forty thousand dollars on a new
chevrolet today but you know cost them a
new car your tuition the discrepancy is
it damaged how did I do you're not
convinced it's hot about sixty percent
of our students get financially of some
amount we do our very best to meet their
their needs but we're not able to meet
all needs and a lot of students come
here every year with a gap between what
we've knowledge to be their family need
and how much you're able to do and how
they come or never quite sure they get
it from Uncle Joe summer and we're not
happy about this is why I'm endow
undergraduate scholarships represent our
number one priority in our captain and
why we've launched a recent mini
campaign poster session and we call fuel
the fire which is all focused on student
support and so
let's finish one last question ok last
question our new loyal Scott Yeshe and
then we'll go to the student calendar
this has to do with faculty didn't
mention it in your opening address I'd
like you to discuss faculty pretension
and whether you the university attracted
some good new professors during the past
few years that there are worthy of
discussion yeah well thanks for asking
that question was what about faculty are
we able to continue to hire attract the
best I would say good new faculty and
retain them in fact the retention of
faculty is one of our major
preoccupations but first let me say we
get phenomenal town and we'd also
there's a very strong to self selection
mechanism that goes on here where you
get faculty who are not not only among
the strongest fact that you find
anywhere in the world but they are there
really are bought into this
interdisciplinary collaboration they
recognize that that's what we do so well
and I come in here that's the kind of
environment that can take advantage of
that's the kind of person indicators of
the strength of our faculty
last month three of our professors were
inducted elected in National Academy
only about 50 or 60 people nationally
elected in the Academy so for Carnegie
Mellon well small to get three that's
big that's a lot of one you at your
thumb better is when we have four so
that's an occasional quality another is
how successful they are in winning
grants and what is an extremely
competitive sponsored research process
our faculty are just too reticent be
given more than our share I just tell
you one to a private statistic private
because National Science Foundation
would never acknowledge this and talk
about they had a special funding program
it ended a little two or three years ago
in computer science in and had the
National Science of commission and while
that program lasted Carnegie Mellon
faculty on more grants from that program
than any state not any any other
university and then he statement except
california you get that in other words
get up all the universities in Illinois
University Chicago Northwestern
University of Illinois and all in all
the funding that went Illinois he was
less than occurring mill we won more
grants they're all very competitive and
any other state that's empty Oliver and
trivially
I said that's shows you tremendous
problem another indication just
yesterday US news and world report
issued its graduate school rankings
computer science is ranked number one
engineering was ranked number six
business is ranked number 16 statistics
first time there were ranked statistics
was ranked number 9 we should be higher
but that's very good from very small
statistics department math was ranked in
the 30s but number three in logic and
list goes on even in those programs
where over all the apartments not ranked
very high we've got individual programs
which are among fearing us so the
business school I 716 but information
technology and business remember to
computational finance that they ranked
in hands down would be no and the list
goes on so there's no question I think
you might about of the quality of the
productivity the faculty we made some
very key hires in recent years we hired
a new director of our Center for the
neural basis of cognition that's all
story in itself it's one of the we're
told by the experts that third the top
programs and it was a very big higher we
attracted humor on university was very
big deal just hired a very dynamic new
leader for human-computer interaction
programme from Northwestern now finally
retention that might be our biggest
challenge becomes the faculty we are
being raided and continuously across the
entire universe and it's a constant
challenge to fend off the springs and
and it's generally richer universities
which offer in my view outrageous
packages and salaries he had one guy I
will tell you the name I will tell you
that was Princeton involved which
offered this guy salary twice what he
was making here and said to him as long
as you're a Princeton he'll be the
highest-paid professor person how do you
propose i mean that's how pretty this
guy will win a Nobel Prize we kept them
now we did not match that offer a
comedian close but he understood that he
was part of a special environment his
collaborative environment where he can
do things that he can't believe anyone's
and but this is a constant oh yeah I've
gone on too long and now let me
introduce our wonderful student panels